[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en attendant dodo c'est un spectacle qui
raconte l'amour des parents pour votre
marmaille et des marmailles qui part
dans une quête initiatique à la
recherche du dodo perdu donc pourquoi
venir parce que c'est un très beau
spectacle avec beau travail vidéo
un beau travail de lumière avec beaucoup
de chansons de dans deux comédiens
formidables que sont eric lorette et du
cil renard et à cause ni avec l'autre
mareuil parce que c'est un spectacle qui
peut voir de 7 à 77 ans coule et spawn
merveille dans les sièges où ça va
chacun y trouve son compte
les parents il comprend ce que les
marmailles comprend pas et les
marmailles comprend ce que les parents
et comprend pas du s p est là il peut
faire ça puisque moi me paraît pas à des
spectacles jeune public en général parce
que me trouvais pas mon compte dedans et
donc notre envie là dessus il était
vraiment que ne peut avoir une salle
remplie de parents sans enfant ne peut
avoir aussi une salle remplie des
enfants sans parents et pour l'instant
il marche donc ambitieux oui n'espère
modestement ambitieux
[Musique]
m
marca
la caisse